until now we have worked only with
positive exponents here's a very simple
example to understand negative exponents
consider this number three raise to
minus four since we are familiar with
positive exponents let's understand how
we can write this negative exponent as a
positive exponent we multiply and divide
the number by 3 raise to 4 multiplied by
3 raise to 4 and divided by 3 raised to
4 in short we are multiplying the number
by 1 which will keep the original number
unchanged that equals 3 raised to minus
4 multiplied by 3 raised to 4 divided by
3 raised to 4 we multiplied this with
this and divided by this focus on the
numerator now since the base is the same
we can use the product law to write it
down as 3 raised to minus 4 plus 4 and
we write the denominator as is minus 4
plus 4 equals 0 hence that would equal 3
raised to 0 divided by 3 raised to 4 and
since we know that any nonzero number
raised to 0 equals 1 we can write it
down as 1 divided by 3 raised to 4 let
me repeat this is a very important
property any nonzero number raised to 0
equals 1 this was our original number 3
raised to minus 4 and we got the answer
as 1 divided by 3 raised to 4 so all we
did is change the sign of the exponent
I wrote it under 1 so we can generalize
it as a raise to minus M equals 1
divided by a raise to M where a is not
equal to 0 because if a is equal to 0
then we would have 0 in the denominator
which would make it in determinate
this term is read as a raise to negative
power M
there's a very simple trick we need to
understand here consider three raise to
minus four when we have to write it down
as a positive exponent it equals 1
divided by 3 raise to 4 so all we did
here is change the sign of the exponent
and wrote it under 1 now consider 21 by
37 the whole raised to minus 7 to write
it down as a positive exponent we write
it down as 1 divided by 21 by 37 the
whole raise to 7 again we just changed
the sign of the exponent
I wrote it under 1 the same trick can be
used for positive exponents to now
consider 4 raised to 3 we can write it
down as 1 divided by 4 raised to minus 3
we change the sign of the exponent
I wrote it under 1
you